you know there's one really awful thing
about the new studio is that I'm losing
this vantage point I have I know you
can't see frilled I won't be able to
watch Freddie so thrilled that's the one
thing I'm looking forward I am bum what
do you see by the way I've always been
able to watch Fred's eating ritual see
now I'll be able to watch her eating
rituals which is gonna be great you know
the way he handles the cards yeah when
he's back there mouthing off at you when
you can't hear him right when he's
mumbling I get to see a whole shoe I'll
be able to watch you which he's still in
that eating ritual thing you know what I
haven't noticed food so much lately it's
slipping here staring at you all the
time
he's got more coffee you know like the
latest thing that I have noticed now I
told you about that how here's this
thermos full of coffee and he brings in
a little cup and he go through menopause
[Laughter]
yeah I was a little tiny demitasse he
uses that as the cup yeah and what do
you get good for one sip and so he does
this and it's got about two sips in it
yeah and well I built the thermos
doesn't take off the top you know that
inner top completely he just screws that
up a little bit yeah if any poor Fred
why don't you just put it in a big cup
this is what happens when you don't have
a life all you have is cats and no
furniture but Fred it's almost like a
shot glass then Cup why not just pour it
into a coffee cup do I comment on your
blender no but you can why comment on
her seaweed wrap do I comment on all her
yes do good things that she does yeah
not well no one can see what I can't see
but now I will I'm jealous I want to see
what Fred's doing
do you wanna know why I always gonna be
a shame Robin because now all you have
is your stupid cats and your horse you
know what I've always maintained that I
could have
you have Fred but I lock him off a book
something I build a wall because I would
be so distracted that I would only talk
about for absolutely absolutely must be
so in love with me I'm talking to you I
just focus on you one time I looked over
and I saw Fred where he hits the sound
effect and I got so hypnotized Mike I'm
doing yeah and he really gets into it
it's called having fun he is like Peter
do as you please oh here I can sit here
and you know Fred will get into his
little things where he's you know pours
his little nuts out on the post up out
of there what up to his yogurt man what
I used to drink his yogurt you already
stop doing that
what happened Fred why did you stop that
Cheers I just don't I'm not at yo Gert
anymore cuz Fred had this whole ritual
where he would take the yogurt he
wouldn't use a spoon he held it like
this and then he would just drink down
in one swallow okay
come on where is he going he stopped he
stopped that he couldn't take it he left
I know you did two hours about it on the
air and then he usually he stops
whatever he's doing after we talked
about it what else did he do used to do
he used to have a little bag of like
nuts
today you are yeah you know like raisins
and nuts and an apple what happened to
the raisin nuts and Apple wood laid them
all out on the ground
really you stop that three years ago
when you build that wall you miss out on
all I know I didn't know you stopped
well I talk about anywhere cuz he
stopped doing he but we used to having
the nuts and what are you we doing the
show now right now it's just coffee
that's right aren't you hungry I know
why cuz you get heavy so you cut it down
yeah basically I really to my weight as
opposed to other people around here
watch other people
will you ever stop chewing on your pens
no I won't but I will suggest that
someone else start chewing on I'm
fascinated by you by you too Robin I
love watching you that's all I love
watching you two treat each other when
they love each other I just missed the
whole show
I don't know truthfully though Fred
doesn't sound complement you know as you
said I am complimented but he doesn't
sour
I'm truly saying I'm going to miss being
able to watch you and you think it's a
slam it's part of your routine oh sure
no it's part of Robins routine I've
enjoyed every moment of that and I've
enjoyed every minute of this too Robin
Roberts doing a tribute like the same
tribute she does to me when she helps
point out that my teeth are too big and
I need my fix
please she's not the only one point you
know what it's like though it's like
that that 10 year old kind of love that
little girls like you know they kick
little boys she doesn't like school it's
weird
he doesn't love French anything bad
about Fred no have I lied about Fred no
no it's not the bad no not now see I
know you got show to do Howard but if
you want to tell the truth what have I
done what have you done what she's
mention you eat nuts no she definitely
paints it to where it's like a
humiliating experience but I'm but I'm
pointing it out to her do you want to
sit there and just yell at her see I
don't hate her I know you know she's
Howie right if I say fred has come up
with a new ritual and I just tell you
what it is
he gets insulted how he's very sensitive
he's sensitive and you're not I have
done nothing
or not but observe and report